do you even want a date like right now  because you you um  so I know some people when their kids  are young like just don't want to date  how do you like feel about that I think  it has more to do with  where I'm at emotionally and it's not  even like a jaded thing right it's more  of I know my value I can talk to I can  have one conversation with a guy now  and I know exactly what he's about  so most of the guys that have presented  themselves in front of me just want to  [ __ ] me  I'm not interested in that and I'm going  to keep my I'm going to keep an open  mind and I'm going to keep an open heart  but I know by how a man approaches me  how he speaks to me I know that there's  that that he wants more with me it